We have M controlled unitary operations that each have cost big O of N squared.
So the total cost here
is big O of N cubed.
And finally, the quantum Fourier transform has cost big O of n squared.
So the total cost is big O of N cubed.
In particular, we see that even with our
module exponentiation trick, the cost of the controlled
unitary operations dominates.
But nevertheless, the cost
is polynomial in little n.
There are also some classical
computations required, like computing the modular exponentiations and running the continued
fraction algorithm,
but those computations
also have polynomial cost. And in fact, they can be done in big O of N cubed operations as well.
There's only one remaining issue, and that is that we need to get our hands on one of these eigenvectors.
How can we do this?
The solution is actually very simple. We don't run the circuit
on an eigenvector.
We just run it on the state one, meaning the binary
encoding of the number one, which we're thinking
about as an element of ZN.
So let's make that
replacement in the diagram.
The reason this works is because of this equation right here.
The state cat one is in
fact a uniform superposition of the R eigenvectors that
we've been talking about.
And that's not immediately obvious, but if you calculate the
sum, you should get cat one.
And if we run the circuit on this state, the output that we'll get
will be exactly the same as if we'd randomly chosen J
and run the procedure on
the eigenvector psi J.
Again, that's not obvious, but an analysis reveals it to be true.
And finally, that is it. We have an efficient quantum
algorithm for order finding.
There's one very short part
of the lesson remaining and a concerns the relationship between integer factorization
and order finding.
I mentioned that if we can solve the order finding problem efficiently, then we can also factor
integers efficiently.
And I want to very briefly give you the main idea for how this works.
It's completely classical. This part actually has nothing
to do with quantum computing.
Here's a method for finding
a non-trivial factor of a given positive integer N.
And by the way, this method only works when N is an odd number, and it's not a prime
number raised to a power.
Those two cases when N
is even or a prime power can be handled separately.
There are efficient classical methods for both detecting and
handling those two cases.
This method is probabilistic. It might fail, but the
probability of failure will be at most a half,
and we can simply run it
multiple times independently to reduce the probability
of error exponentially fast.
First, we choose A between
two and N minus one at random, uniformly.
Then we compute the GCD of A and N.
And if the GCD happens
to be larger than one, then we've just been incredibly lucky.
The GCD will be a factor of N and we can just output it and stop.
Otherwise, the algorithm continues on and we now know that A is in ZN star.
And now we compute the order of A, which is where we need a quantum computer.
Or maybe we have a different
way to compute the order. The algorithm doesn't really
care where it comes from, but the only way that we know
how to do this efficiently
is with a quantum computer.
If the order of R is even, then we compute the GCD of
A to the power R over two minus one with N.
And if that GCD is larger than one, then again we have a factor of N, so we output it and we stop.
Otherwise the algorithm has failed. And in that case, we
can go back to the start and choose a different A
and hope for a better
outcome the next time around.
And that's it. And by the way, once
we found a factor of N, we can recurs on both that factor
and divide it by that factor until we have a prime factorization of N.
So why should this work?
Well, there are two main points. The first is that because A to the power R is congruent to one modular N,
we have that N divides A
to the power R minus one.
Those two statements
are actually equivalent. This is the definition of mod N that you'll find in number theory books.
Second, if R is even, then this equation that
we have here is true.
This is the well-known formula
for a difference of squares.
In fact, the equation is true for all R, but we need R over two to
be an integer in step four.